so Heinrich Rohrer
welcome to Stockholm into this interview
with nobelprize.org you were awarded the
1986 Nobel Prize in Physics together
with Ernst Ruska and GERD Binnig for
your joint work in developing microscopy
and in particular you and GERD Binnig
were received the prize for your design
of the scan and scanning tunneling
microscope now this is a device that it
enables us to look at the surface of
objects at the atomic scale by means of
a probe which paths skims over the
surface and records variations in the
topography below it with minut current
fluctuations what did this device enable
us to see for the first time that we
hadn't seen before as you say your
surface structures in a different way I
mean you had some ideas about certain
surface structures but you never saw it
in so to speak in real space so it's
just like if you would trace a surface
with your finger you see so you see it
in the real space and then of course
actually you see the electrons on the
surface it's it's electronic wave
functions and and so you also can see
certain properties you can see you can
you can test the hardness of a surface
but then of course in this in the same
way you also can take atoms the
principle is the same as if you take
your fingers and you play around with
small balls and the things this if you
take none of things the small balls can
be atoms and it's exactly the same thing
you can they take an atom you can put it
somewhere else or you can take your
fingers and glide over the surface and
feel the surface
feel the bumps and salt so it's the same
fingers you can do two chops you can
change it or you can feel it you see you
can detect it or you can move it around
you can play with it yes right and what
in those early days of using it what
were the first surprises that came up
because as you said you sort of had an
idea and then you could actually see
what what surprises turned out I think
the first surprise was that video they
could do it with atomic resolution you
see actually that you can do it with
atomic resolution that's inherent in the
approach we took but we didn't expect it
that they could make such fine fingers
but then every every point of a needle
ends up with one atom and this very
adamant that's then your finger you see
and that's this atom is there has the
size of an atom and so you can feel
other atoms that's and that was a
pleasant surprise that you could do it
relatively easy I mean on the subject of
being able to do it it seems
unimaginably complex to make such a
thing that you have because you are
talking about atoms in almost in contact
with other atoms there has been no
vibration you're talking about a probe
which is as you say one atom thick at
its tip one the mind boggles how did how
did you have the confidence to even
imagine that one could do such a thing
to make such an instrument or let's say
we didn't see any any obstacle which
could not be our could not be overcome
and of course there were quite a few
fort wishes developments in the whole
thing but somehow luck was on our side
but I think you always I mean in science
you need love if you see that sir
and if you don't have to look in a
specific case then you do something
different you might have luck in
something else so that's you see it was
less difficult
finally when everybody's home
that's why everybody thought you could
not do it and that's why nobody did it
and that's I would say a crucial thing
in science you see everything is new
because other people think you cannot do
it or because other people do not
appreciate that they could be become
important and we live of novelty in
science so whenever you do something new
you have to overcome certain belief that
it cannot be done that it is not
interesting and so on so I mean it's
interesting to ask why you and get then
it believed that you could do it that
other people were were bounded by the
limitations of what they thought they
could do you too felt that there were no
obstacles there was nothing
insurmountable you use a phrase in your
autobiography that you wrote for when
you when you receive the Nobel Prize
that you'd lost your respect for
angstroms and that's a lovely phrase an
angstrom being 10 to the minus 10 meters
you okay okay I did I did in my PhD
thesis I did work where I work let's say
we sang star dimensions just
mechanically so I weren't scared of the
size and you see this work and so in
principle at that time I knew you can
measure angstroms you see mechanically
of the more or less mechanically so why
shouldn't you be able to do it in this
way and so in retrospect it's always
easy yes or let's put it this way when I
give lectures to the public I always
have a little bit the problem I tell
them listen if I explain you now what we
did in terms that you don't understand
it you go home and still wonder what the
disguise - and if I explain it to you in
terms that you understand it then you
ask yourself what for something such
simple you get the Nobel Prizes
okay in any case it worked out nicely
yes yes indeed there's another phrase
you use you talk about the
lightheartedness of your approach that
you you approach things with perhaps
less seriousness I don't know that maybe
that's not the right word there was less
sort of it was less momentous to do what
you were doing then then other people
might have felt it was about to be yes
okay I think both get Bennigan's IV are
not not the types who are who how would
you say would hang themselves because of
a failure and the second thing is in
either IBM laboratory we had really the
freedom of doing things and especially
that sort of get it always explained it
we had the freedom to make mistakes and
so I think that's something very
important and unfortunately it is
freedom for scientists gets more and
more lost you see all the agencies
everybody is looking at scientists and
but they should be able to make mistakes
then they can correct it you see
otherwise you just do the common things
you don't dare to do something something
beyond what everybody else thinks it's
hard to describe as artists as a
productive unit which is going to make
this contribution in this time is I'd
like to talk a little bit about there
was the IBM research labs and the
environment there because that's a quite
an unusual environment this is the this
is a Research Institute where people are
free to pursue projects that are not
everybody okay yes oh really so there's
a different physicists are treated a
little bit differently there or yes you
see people who work on technology
I think that's usually a joint effort of
many people whereas the physics we did
this type of physics where everybody
could do his own project on his own
maybe we some Hey
of a definition or a four-poster core of
a PhD student
whereas in in technology you have to
make concentrated efforts toward
something and there of course a certain
freedom gets lost you still even in
technology you have to freedom to solve
a problem your way you see but it's
never so nice it's in a certain
framework whereas in the physics
everybody had to come up with his own
idea what he was going to do it was
obviously an environment the suited you
well you joined in 1963 and and stayed
there for the whole of your career
pretty much correct you know it's a
pleasant atmosphere I mean you had to
work hard you had you had to show
something you see you had to perform
let's see put this way you have to
perform
I mean if too long if you took too long
time to get something out which could be
published in a reasonable paper or if
you don't work did you if you did not
get the recognition of the scientific
community for too long a time then I
think it really would have gotten a
little bit less pleasant and I think
that happens with certain people even in
the idea of lab in Syracuse yet but I we
were in the fortunate situations that
things worked and you changed fields a
few times along the way and yes how did
you make the decisions about which feels
to pursue what was that IBM directed or
where they just you know that serve
older did the research staff member are
responsible for their own field and
finding their own their own topics you
see they they are their own how to say
things they have to make their own work
you see that so this
I was working on her on a set of
problems before and I thought somehow I
came now I came as far as I could go
without learning completely new things
that's in clinical phenomenon and that
was a very interesting topic and it was
more or less at the top of it the
interests so by making everything
smaller inhomogeneities play a more
important role so if you have a an oxide
which has a few holes then the
conduction of electricity through this
oxide is maybe a little bit larger now
if you have 100 holes then you have the
same type of if you make another batch
of oxide you might have 98 holes and
then maybe the conductivity would be
different it simply by 2 percent so the
fluctuation from piece to piece is still
small but if you make things smaller and
smaller then you mind up at patches
where you just have 2 or 3 holes you see
now maybe this one has two holes and
this one has three holes and this one
has one hole so then the holes effective
conductivity moves so then in one case
you would have a tremendous conductivity
and in the other case would have a
conductivity which is 2 times less or
something like that and that these are
the fluctuations from from piece to
piece which cannot be tailed tolerated
in miniaturization and so that's an idea
to work along these lines and nobody did
it really an IPM and it was an important
problem now in this case it was in
opportunity at oxide but you can have
many different ways of there where
inhomogeneities play an important role
and so small and something becomes some
more
they're all often on bikini pit near
they can get the disasters well I want
to return to the theme of
miniaturization in general a little
later but thinking about this the the
the the the decades that I've been at
the IBM research labs where you move
through various fields and change do you
think that as well as being wanting to
move on because you had reached the
pinnacle of success in a particular
field there was also an element of
feeling that as a as a newcomer but
inexperienced newcomer to another field
you could make a significant
contribution fast I think that's a check
that's generally through an unfortunate
we do not practice so you see if you
look at nobody price work that's very
often done at a young age in physics
particularly in physics but even in are
such things tools and that simple
because young people are not yet biased
in their mind they are not completely
taken by their expert opinions and you
see expert opinions have a difficulty to
go beyond of what say no and so that's
when you start in a new field you are
from the point of view of scientists
you certainly are 20 years younger
because in the new field you are not a
biased and you look at certain things a
little bit more relaxed and a little bit
more open and I think that's important
and unfortunately this type of how do
you say rejuvenation is that so
worthless of of the mind is not taking
place among scientists you see the
scientists do not get help enough help
enough encouragement to change their
field from time to time because the
pressure maybe the pressure is too high
always to perform something and once you
start in a new field you you are nobody
to start with you see you have to make
your way back again but if you have a
little bit self-confidence and you see
you are as good as you would like to be
then now you make it so that that seems
to me to be a question it is it that the
expert becomes so sort of enamored of
the ways that they are thinking about
things that they can't think in new ways
or is it that there's just no pressure
to think about new ways because they're
already the expert in this and and
you're not a nobody or a somebody if you
move into a new field as you say
suddenly you have to make your mark it's
just the pressure of people's
expectation I think the ones would
change change because of themselves and
not because of external pressure yes yes
yes there are I would say an expert in a
field he feels I would say even more
pressure because he has to stay in the
field he isn't is narrow or it's a
narrow way of thinking and then he has
to perform so getting out into something
else might not be necessarily you are
more difficult to see whatever the case
then it's obviously a very fortunate
circumstance that one thought you found
yourself within IBM where they would not
allow to you to make such jumps you
presumably you didn't have to go through
a sort of grant proposal they were happy
yeah they encouraged it they were
happier that that they did something
else not because I was not performing in
that setting but that also little bit
closer to the eye Bay being traced I
find what they did before you see here
but I think generally if somebody tells
some reason I would like to do something
different they are very open and
receptive to something like that that's
wonderfully far side usually I suppose
it brings us to the question of
mentorship a bit presumably there are
there are people running the lab who
have who have been guiding lights for
you at least in in making it an
environment in which one can make this
sort of jump or is it self guided
because you know no that's that simply
say
okay I mean of course you need it maybe
some different resources but you see if
you had that easily record then I think
everybody is smart enough to say listen
if this guy was a reasonably record if
he wants to do something now something
different you should let him do that you
see right because it was my risk does
that dictate your own attitude to
mentorship when when students come
forward with your young people is those
how you treat them yes yeah so I'd like
to talk a little bit about the
relationship the partnership with GERD
Binnig he came to your lab at the
beginning of the project to develop STM
and it was obviously extremely fruitful
how did that work he was your he was
your employee but is he he was not my
employee that's okay I was his manager
but there we take a little bit a
different attitude I had the opportunity
or I had the opportunity to get
something for this type of problems for
the in homogeneity problem and I found I
was fortunate enough to find gap pinic
and then we started discussing and he
liked it that's why he came and then I
think in many case he was the technical
crucial figure in the whole in the whole
development you see and we discussed
everything I mean he is he's the most
creative guy I know simply in his and I
think in many ways you were a very good
compliment Susie and he was mature nice
for me but I think we found a very good
relationship and did you recognize it
immediately was it apparent from the
beginning that it was all gay it was
just the perfect the perfect partnership
no because I think that I think he he he
recognized it earlier studied me but you
see I'm older so I'm a little bit more
maybe conservative in many respects but
but I think it simply worked out and
that was the first team really in
physics to my knowledge that was the
first time two guys got together did
something from this from the IBM labs
right
yeah from our IBM lab and the second
team that was the big not similar who
got the Nobel Prize for their in 1987
year after yes this was obviously
spurred to this work if I didn't resting
these were golden days in Zurich yeah
yeah did okay yes because your team had
started slightly ahead of bed nose and
mother yeah we started in get penny came
end of 78 and 79 we discussed it and out
of this discussion came there is came
the HTML doesn't austere and then okay
the first two years kept first to work
maybe our halftime and he did those
things and I just discussed and I did
mostly other thing so we had Christopher
he was a technician at sir time and he
worked full-time he was my technician
but then he didn't work with me anymore
fever for this problem you see that
that's also something you see it's
always at least I
it's maybe not always easy to start
something new but but it's getting more
difficult if you have to D devote your
own resources you see a lot of people
want to do something new but they always
tell you first what they would need for
doing something you because they don't
really want to give up what they have
and this step for me it was clear okay
that's not a new area so crystal Kerr
police work you know this of this thing
and no longer my being my technician you
see lovely clarity of vision they
weren't they weren't um totally easy
years they're developing STM that there
was quite a lot of opposition people
disbelieve that you were getting the
results that you said you were getting
no I wouldn't say your position I mean
no position we didn't listen okay and we
did not make advertisement for it and I
think that was something very important
I mean the management knew that we were
doing something you are different but we
never had to expose ourselves to the
management with the new thing we still
carried on certain all the experiments
from before and they were successful
enough that we could present ourself as
still good scientist with the old work
and that's why the new work was never we
didn't expose ourselves with the new
work only when it inverted and that was
I think that's very that's very
important that you do not expose
yourself with something new because then
you have to start to make promises you
see sooner or later and I saw too many
technique failures in technology where
people expose them too early and maybe
started to tell things which were a
little bit exaggerated or turned out to
be exaggerated and then you came into a
more
their promises and the reality started
to diverge more and more I suppose to a
certain extent one might even say that
that was the case with bed nose and
moolah can a superconductive ceramics
because the promises there were enormous
yeah but she never she never talked
about deep night any they never expose
themselves before yes
so that's internal exposure but then
there's also external exposure the point
at which you start telling the world in
general what you're doing but now they
only may need to work yeah and then see
a lot of people that are very skeptic
that's right yeah but okay that that was
their problem and so what wonderful
devil-may-care and I mean we knew what
we were doing doing that was real and if
people thought that you cannot do it
even if you could do it that's I think
that's their problem okay and in 1986
if basically the technique had been
proved and very rapidly you were awarded
the Nobel Prize on the back of lots of
other prizes as well did did that change
everything very radically for you did or
did life continue just pretty much I
think okay I think the recognition we
got already before I mean let's say the
recognition in the scientific community
the esteem then of course a Nobel Prize
such maybe discontinuity in the whole
thing but surely changed a few things I
mean okay you are then a Nobel laureate
that's aa little bit different how do
you say extra elevation yes yes that's
so but on the other hand I mean you
haven't been something different you
didn't get it didn't become somebody
different you've got the same person
with the same physics knowledge
everything
and I think we also could behave this
video so that made life easier for us
and for everybody around us and STM was
one of the building blocks of what I
suppose one might call the net the the
nanoscience revolution it was one of
them it opened up a whole new area to
view and that I'd like to ask you a
little bit about the word I used their
revolution because nanoscience is seen
as a revolution is that a corrector is
it changing the way we look at the world
I think that evolution has to have a
little bit more sensors to scale it's
blue that it was getting to a smaller
and smaller cane scale that was always
the beginning of further evolution I
mean you're from that from the exploring
the world with since Columbus you see
that was the world scale and then came
the Industrial Revolution that was the
macro scale - let's say - down to the
micrometer as a precision scale and then
came the IT revolution the information
technology revolution that was in the
scale of micrometer and so but you see
it wasn't the micro revolution it was
really it was the information technology
revolution another one was saying does
the revolution so I would I would hate
to say the Nano revolution you see it
has to have a little bit more substance
i i i have someone i know what the truth
or i have i I have my expectations what
will be what could happen but I don't
have a word for it so now so now just
getting smaller alone does not make the
revolution I mean also for the for the
micro tech
you have to have a transistor which
really changed and the way you could do
things and I think also the
nanotechnology you have to have a few
more ideas the way you will approach new
things we know a little bit what could
be the end of it but but how to do it we
don't know yet it is one point that
having reached the nano scale the atomic
scale we've really reached the limits of
miniaturization we can't really go
smaller so I will guess all yes and so
that's I think we hit the point you see
and we are already very close we have
covered of the miniaturization over the
last 50 as we have current are covered
two-thirds or three-quarters and there
is just a little bit to go the difficult
bit to the nano so just getting smaller
is not it's not all you see I think nano
has to offer like a bit different things
than just being smaller in order to
become a revolution and I think nano
office really completely new prospects
in in many ways would you care to
speculate on let's say properties are
very much different on the nano scale
sensor of the micro scale and on the
macro scale the ways we can do things
are also different you enter really very
closely the area of quantum mechanics
you see you are at that state domain of
atoms or molecules and then you can
think about what how do you work so far
we made things smaller by
miniaturization now when you talk about
atoms and molecules you think in terms
of building up something from the very
small
that there are there are many many ways
justtake molecular recognition we would
like to be able to recognize other
molecules by a specific molecule such as
like nature does it you see and I think
we see that we can do that so I would
say the great merit of the STM is not
just being able to make these fantastic
pictures and so on but I think the great
merit is really that we take now atoms
and molecules and small small structures
of molecules we take them as an
addressable individual you know this is
this atom we want to do something with
this atom with this molecule and it's
not like in chemistry and biology where
all these things anonymous members of
some statistical answer you see and I
think that opens the perspective of a
new way of handling matter and doing
things with matter but absolutely at one
level that nanoscience perhaps began in
physics but it now is a very
interdisciplinary subject which more
than it is a subject people want to
define it as a subject but it has to be
interdisciplinary because it's involved
in all these and biology and chemistry
although they have been based on
statistical ensembles come down imagine
a atom scale and molecules can you do
not have disciplines okay the
disciplines emerged when you go to
larger and larger things that was in the
take 300 years ago or foreign you didn't
talk about physics or what abilities and
then afterwards you had the disciplines
and now we are moving back to the
original way the nanotechnology and so
the disciplines merge again I think it's
naturally development that's that's a
nice drawing to a close of things I just
like to ask one last question which is
based around the idea of moving fields
obviously you've been successful in
moving from field to field what do you
think is it possible to answer
nanoscience would require now in terms
of an influx of new people are there
other people who should who you would
like to see move into the field of
studying properties at the atomic level
the young people and I think she doing
that also meet a meeting you see that
was also the interesting aspect when we
started with the whole Sigma Nu when the
SEM came out to see it was mainly young
people there weren't many as established
ones you see the surface scientists
establish surface I'd say state surface
scientists didn't go into the same only
later but but now it's quite interesting
to see when you go to a meeting I've I
was at the last meeting a big meeting
that was the conference in Boston 205
and I've also I was very pleasantly
surprised by the by the young people you
see there was so many young people with
young guys with their enthusiasm and in
particular a lot of young women who get
involved in nanoscience and not just in
the biological place or the biological
area they they get involved in in real
heart let's say mechanical engineering
or Electrical Engineering in context
with nanoscience I think that that's for
me a very encouraging sign when also
young women get now really enthusiastic
about something
oh she gets you good homes it's a very
nice place to place to stop thank you
very much indeed for speaking to us
Heinrich Rohrer and enjoy the rest of
your stay in stock